so you're given this jar of marbles and
this is one of those games where you
have to try to guess how many marbles
are in the jar and say for example you
guess that there is 83 marbles but in
actuality there is only 80 marbles and
you want to calculate what's your
percent error so how do you do that well
the formally you want to use here is the
percent error is the error divided by
the actual amount so the error means
like how far off are you well you
guessed 83 there was actually 80 so you
were actually off by three marbles
compared to what though compared to how
many there were actually in the jar so
it's going to be three divided by eighty
let's go to the calculator on that see
what that comes out to so three divided
by eighty which is point zero three
seven five and we want to just move that
decimal place two places to the right to
convert it to a percentage so it's a
three point seven five percent error now
if you're talking about percent change
say for example you go to the store and
the original price of an item is forty
dollars but then the next time you go
the new price is 52 dollars and you just
want to figure out what percent changes
that well when you do percent change you
want the new amount minus the original
amount divided by the original amount so
what you're doing is you're figuring out
how much is it changing by okay new
minus original divided by what it was to
begin with not the new price but the
original price so let's go ahead and do
that so the new price is $52 - $40
divided by the original price because we
want to see how it changed compared to
how it was so this comes out to 12
divided by 40 let's go to the calculator
again and that comes out to 0.3 and we
just want to move that decimal place two
places to the right we're going to put a
placeholder here so it comes out to 30%
now this is a 30% increase if this
quantity here came out negative that
would be a percent decrease and you got
it if you're reviewing your pre-algebra
skills check out my pre-algebra review
video right over there and I'll see you
in that video